[Musik]
Russland attackiert in der Ukraine
gezielt zivile Infrastruktur während die
Debatte um Sanktionen Deutschland an
Schärfe gewinnt Pop-Titan Dieter Bohlen
findet alles nur Scheiße große Wellen
schlug auch ein Gastbeitrag in der
Süddeutschen Zeitung von Natalie
Weidenfeld die Schlagzeile woher kommt
die Kriegsbegeisterung westlicher
intellektueller Frau Weidenfeld ist
heute Abend auch bei uns sie ist
französisch-deutsche Schriftstellerin
und Kulturwissenschaftlerin schön dass
Sie da sind mein nächster Gast ist Fritz
Felgentreu er ist SPD-Politiker Lehrer
und ehemaliger verteidigungspolitischer
Sprecher der SPD sein Thema heute abend
Deutschland muss der Ukraine weiterhin
mit allen Mitteln helfen auch mit von
der Partie Gerhard Schindler er ist
ehemaliger Präsident des
Bundesnachrichtendienst da denkt man
direkt an große Geheimnisse ich bin
gespannt was ja und so verraten wird und
Jurist er fordert heute abend
Friedensverhandlungen last but not least
Martin Frost er ist Experte für Cyber
Security und Cyberkriminalität erfindet
das sind Deutschland die Sensibilität
Cybercrime fehlt da ist ich muss ich
zugestehen ich bin damit auch nicht sehr
bewandert mit dem Thema wir werden heute
Abend viel lernen starten möchten wir
aber jetzt die Sendung erstmal mit
meinem Kollegen Bild vizeparonsheimer
seit Monaten ist er vor Ort in der
Ukraine kein deutscher Journalist hat
Präsident selenski öfter zum Interview
getroffen guten Abend Paul
schön dich zu sehen erstmals seit
Monaten schlugen ja Anfang der Woche
wieder Raketen Kiew ein welches Bild
bietet sich dir
am Anfang der Woche ein absolutes Bild
des Schreckens das was ich in den
vergangenen Monaten im Osten im Süden
dort erlebt habe zurück in Kiew und vor
allem Anschläge auf Zivilisten also
Raketen mitten in der Stadt besonders
mitgenommen hat mich die Begegnung mit
einem Vater der seine 36-Jährige Tochter
verloren hat sie war auf dem Weg zur
Arbeit zu einem Krankenhaus dort
schlugen dann die russischen Raketen ein
sie hinterlässt ein fünfjährigen Sohn
das sind die Schicksale die hier ja was
man hier in der Ukraine sehen kann und
gleichzeitig ist es aber so dass viele
Ukraine direkt wieder zum Alltag
übergegangen sind und gesagt haben wir
müssen weitermachen die Straßen wurden
wieder ausgebessert dennoch gab es auch
jetzt wieder in diesen Stunden
raketenalarm rund um Kiew
es ist bewundernswert Paul wie du auch
sagst dass die Menschen versuchen zum
Alltag zurückzukehren in Deutschland
treiben ja viele Menschen die Angst vor
Putins Atomwaffen um in der Ukraine
wahrscheinlich besonders hältst du denn
den Einsatz taktischer Atomwaffen für
möglich
ich halte den Einsatz von taktischen
Nuklearwaffen für absolut möglich das
ist eine Möglichkeit die Putin hat der
hat da mehrfach mit bedroht gedroht
interessanterweise war es so dass wir
erlebt haben dass im Präsidentenpalast
und als wir da an diesen Tagen waren
dass der Einsatz momentan für etwas
unwahrscheinlicher gehalten wird da wird
damit argumentiert dass Putin das in den
letzten Tagen der letzten Woche eben
nicht mehr wiederholt habe was würde
passieren bei einem taktischen
Nuklearangriff wahrscheinlich so muss
man das sagen würde nicht Kiew oder eine
andere Großstadt angegriffen sondern
davon gehen Experten aus Putin könnte
versuchen mit einem taktischen
Nuklearschlag in der Front etwas zu tun
also im Osten und im Süden das halte ich
theoretisch für möglich allerdings sagen
Experten das Putin dann eben natürlich
auch die Unterstützung von Ländern wie
China verl könnte also er würde auch
einiges riskieren aus geostrategischer
Perspektive
ist ja Dieter Bohlen und der hat
ziemlich für Furore gesorgt weil mir
doch einmal rein
aber ich bin eben der Meinung
wir sind ihr könnt mich ruhig ausruhen
ja aber wenn die diese Sanktionen zum
Beispiel nicht gemacht hätten und man
hätte sich vernünftig an einen Tisch
gesetzt ja dann bräuchten die Leute sich
jetzt nicht den ganzen Firlefanz machen
ja die Leute jetzt müssen wir frieren
jetzt müssen wir dies und das das ist
doch alles scheiße von aus meiner Sicht
ja man kann das jetzt sehen okay mit dem
kriechen Ukraine man kann das immer
alles aber ich meine alles was da so
passiert und das Russland jetzt für viel
viel mehr Geld Gast nach Asien verkauft
und das ist ja ich meine das verstehe
ich alles nicht mehr jetzt
Paul wie ordnest du die Aussage von
Dieter Bohlen ein du hast ja auch mit
Wladimir Klitschko ein Interview dazu
geführt
aus meiner Sicht ist
Dieter Bohlen dort auf russische
Propaganda reingefallen so klar muss man
das sagen also zunächst einmal
diejenigen die gegen Sanktionen
argumentieren die müssen zu Wort kommen
und es ist auch wichtig dass es diese
Debatte gibt über Sinnhaftigkeit oder
nicht Sinnhaftigkeit von Sanktionen aber
die Art und Weise wie Dieter Bohlen über
diesen Krieg spricht über Wladimir Putin
spricht auch über die Ukraine spricht
die weiß doch auf dass er sich damit
offenbar nicht wirklich beschäftigt hat
fangen wir mit den Verhandlungen an also
Dieter Bohlen sagt es habe ja gar keine
Verhandlungen gegeben und man hätte sich
ja einfach mal an einen Tisch setzen
können das ist faktisch falsch vor dem
Krieg haben so will ja Emmanuel macron
als auch Olaf Scholz und andere ist
versucht mit Wladimir Putin ins Gespräch
zu kommen diese beiden an einen Tisch zu
bekommen es gibt sogar Aussagen von
russischen offiziellen die in
amerikanischen Medien zitiert werden die
sagen Wladimir Putin wollte all das vor
dem Krieg nicht hören man muss immer
wieder sagen er wollte diesen Krieg er
hat geglaubt dass er hier die Ukraine
überrennen kann dass die Menschen ihm
zujubeln und er hat die Existenz der
Ukraine in Frage gestellt das zweite ist
er sagt dass die Sanktionen nichts
bringen würden also er verallgemeinert
sehr spricht da den Rubel unter anderem
an was richtig ist der Rubel ist nicht
so
runtergefallen wie Experten oder wie
auch Europa das gehofft hatte aber
bringen deshalb alle Sanktionen nichts
nein gerade wenn man sich bestimmte
Wirtschaftsbereiche anschaut die
sensiblen Bereiche also insbesondere die
Frage von Waffenlieferungen russland hat
große Probleme jetzt Chips zu bekommen
also sozusagen dieses Thema weiter
auszubauen das ist nur eine von vielen
Dingen die man in dem
hochtechnologiebereich sieht wo die
Sanktionen sehr wohl etwas bringen und
die ist Isolation auch vielen vielen
große Sorgen macht auch wenn man die
gesamten Wirtschaftsdaten anschaut das
dritte ist
Dieter Bohlen sagt man muss diesen Krieg
beenden ja natürlich muss man diesen
Krieg be dann aber wer kann den Krieg
beenden Wladimir Putin nämlich indem er
sagt raus aus der Ukraine Truppen raus
und der Krieg wäre beendet also ich
glaube dass das sehr gefährlich ist vor
allem wie Dieter Bohlen hier formuliert
hat
Herr Schindler paronsheimer sagt es ist
sehr gefährlich wie Dieter Bohlen hier
argumentiert hat wie sehen Sie das also
im großen und ganzen Teil ist die
Auffassung die Herr Ronzheimer hier
vertreten hat
es ist allerdings so dass wir schon
darauf achten müssen dass wir uns nicht
instrumentalisieren lassen weder von der
Ukraine noch von beispielsweise den
US-Amerikanern wir müssen eine aktive
Friedenspolitik betreiben und die
bedeutet wir müssen immer wieder
innehalten und sagen kann das so
weitergehen wie es gerade läuft und da
bin ich der Auffassung dass Menschen wie
Bohlen etwas zum Ausdruck bringen was
sicherlich noch stärker werden wird
nämlich eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit mit
dieser Entwicklung weil man kein Ende
sieht und wer kein hier sieht weiß nicht
was er macht und wenn ich weiß was er
macht der ist unsicher diese
Unsicherheit die gilt es zu beseitigen
da können wir heute Abend gerne ein
Stück weit drüber reden Frau Weidenfeld
sehen sie auch kein Ende in Sicht ja ich
sehe vor allem kein Ende in Sicht in
einer gewissen Haltung die den Krieg als
als einzige Möglichkeit sieht oder immer
weitere Aufrüstung und ich denke es muss
auch auch im intellektuellen Milieu ein
Fundament geschaffen werden dass man
andere Optionen einfach aufmacht was
wäre für sie so eine Option also Krieg
will ja eigentlich niemand ich kann mir
kaum vorstellen dass jemand Krieg möchte
das heißt was wäre die Option wie könnte
man Wladimir Putin einen Tisch bekommen
also ich bin jetzt kein Militärexperte
aber sagen ich rede jetzt hier als
Kulturwissenschaftlerin und da denke ich
ist es ganz wichtig dass wir
runterkommen von möglichen Projektionen
sie sagen wir dürfen uns nicht
beeinflussen lassen weder von
ukrainische noch von russischer Seite
ich denke mal Kriegspropaganda gibt es
wahrscheinlich auf beiden Seiten
das Russland den Angriffskrieg geführt
hat und im Unrecht ist darüber sind wir
uns alle einig aber es das ist meine
Diagnose ist findet es finden alle
möglichen Idealisierungen und
Projektionen statt gerade leider auch
bei vielen intellektuellen nicht alle
aber viele und das ist gefährlich denn
gerade auch intellektuelle haben eine
gewisse Macht die beanspruchen sie auch
für sich dass Sie wissen wo es lang geht
und wir müssen da runterkommen und die
Realität sehen am Krieg ist erstmal
wenig heldenhaftes sondern wir haben es
ja gerade gesehen wir haben also
Verständnis für Dieter Bohlen grauen ach
Dieter Bohlen redet immer so wie in der
Schnabel gewachsen ist also ich würde es
jetzt nicht überbewerten und das jetzt
gerade als Zeichen sehen dass er von der
russischen Seite jetzt indoktriniert
worden ist sondern einfach mal wieder
blöd locker formuliert ich würde dann
nicht mehr in eine interpretieren eine
Frage ich würde gerne noch einmal
peronsheimer dazu der uns auch weiterhin
zugeschaltet ist Paul gerade wurde
gesagt dass es auch Propaganda
Kriegspropaganda von beiden Seiten geben
würde wie würdest du das einordnen
ich finde das erstmal sozusagen eine ja
Verniedlichung der der russischen Seite
denn erstmal muss man sagen und dass das
was ich als Reporter erlebt habe das hat
Grausamkeiten auf der russischen Seite
zu Tage gefördert ich war ein
Botschafter als die Menschen dort auf
der Straße lagen Zivilisten noch mit den
Händen verbunden auf dem Rücken
erschossen ich war in den
foltergefängnissen in isum im Osten des
Landes ich war mit Menschen dort die
dort gefoltert wurden die mir berichtet
haben wie Elektroschocks eingesetzt
wurden andere Menschen die Schreie
gehört haben Massengräber die dort die
ist dort gibt also man muss einmal
festhalten in allen befreiten Gebieten
in denen ich war nachdem das passiert
ist überall kamen diese Groll Taten zu
Tage und jedes Ort jeder Ort der jetzt
noch besetzt ist von den Russen da
müssen wir davon ausgehen das sind
diesen Minuten wo wir reden in
darknästen die Menschen gefoltert werden
und das ist der große Unterschied muss
man sagen zu dem was im ukrainischen
Regionen passiert die Ukraine ist eine
Demokratie auch wenn immer versucht wird
sozusagen sie in irgendeine Richtung zu
rücken natürlich hat die Ukraine als
Staat auch große Probleme gehabt aber
wir können das ganze nicht gleichsetzen
das ist glaube ich sehr wichtig und was
Propaganda angeht der große Unterschied
ist wir dürfen hier frei berichten ich
war im Gebieten und habe zum Beispiel
aufgedeckt auch auf ukrainischer Seite
als das ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerium davon
gesprochen hat das bestimmte Dinge dort
vorgefallen sind da ging es um Zähne die
angeblich dort gefangenen entrissen sein
sollen da haben wir aufgedeckt dass das
eben nicht der Fall ist wir können aber
frei recherchieren wir können mit den
Menschen sprechen in Russland gibt es
ausschließlich ausschließlich staatliche
Propaganda Fernsehsender die eben nur
berichten was Putin sehen will und ich
glaube diese Unterschiede muss man immer
wieder ganz ganz klar machen und ich bin
ehrlicher ehrlicherweise glücklich das
ist viele Menschen gibt und das ist auch
viel intellektuelle gibt die das klar
sehen klar ansprechen und auch klar
aussprechen das hat nichts damit zu tun
dass irgendjemand Krieg will ich als
jemand der seit über zehn Jahren Krieg
gesehen hat
kann Ihnen das ganz sicher sagen niemand
möchte das was wir hier erleben irgendwo
sehen
wenn Sie das Hören auch die Worte von
paronsheim auch von den Gräueltaten und
sie waren ja verteidigungspolitische
Sprecher der SPD was kann die deutsche
Regierung denn tun
vor allen Dingen muss man sich klar
machen warum wollen wir denn die Ukraine
überhaupt unterstützen und das eine eine
Reihe von Gründen hat ja Paul ronsheimer
eben schon ausgeführt einfach aufgrund
der gewaltigen Ungerechtigkeiten und
Verbrechen die dort begangen worden sind
aber es gibt auch einen globalen Aspekt
was bedeutet es eigentlich für unser
aller Sicherheit wenn eine Großmacht wie
Russland sich damit durchsetzte ihre
Ziele erreicht dass sie einen
Angriffskrieg führt also praktisch das
größte Verbrechen begeht das in den
Beziehungen zwischen Völkern und Staaten
überhaupt möglich ist und sich dann auch
noch durchsetzt in dem sie mit dem
Einsatz von Atomwaffen droht was was
löst das weltweit aus was für Lehren
werden da ausgezogen für Russland ganz
klar wenn das einmal geklappt hat wird
es auch wieder klappen also wenn man
jetzt beispielsweise ein
Waffenstillstand hätte dann hätte
Russland einen Sieg errungen es hätte
eine Landbrücke hergestellt zwischen den
bereits besetzten Gebieten im
donutsbecken und der Krim es hätte ein
Fünftel der Ukraine besetzt sind dann
Aufmarschgebiet gewonnen für den
nächsten Krieg und das hat ja gelernt
wenn wir nur hart genug vorgehen wenn
wir nur streng genug drohen scharf genug
d dann knicken die anderen ein
irgendwann wollen sie an
Waffenstillstand und wir schneiden
wieder ein Scheibchen von der Ukraine ab
das ist keine Ukraine mehr gibt aber
nicht nur Russland würde ja dieser
Konsequenzen ziehen sondern Diktatoren
Aggressoren weltweit würden lernen wie
man das macht wenn man nur hart genug
auftritt wenn man nur mit genug
Vernichtung droht und ultimative
Vernichtung ist ja die Atomwaffen
verstehen sie denn die Sorgen der Bürger
auch in Deutschland ich verstehe die
Sorgen absolut ich mache mir nur Sorgen
ob es nicht noch alles für unsicherer
und gefährlicher wird weltweit wenn wir
jetzt an dieser Stelle ist nicht
schaffen das Stoppschild aufzurichten
und zu sagen bis hierhin und nicht
weiter diese Art miteinander umzugehen
in den Beziehungen zwischen Völkern und
Staaten die haben wir nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg für alle Zeiten verbannen
wollen von unserem Planeten und jetzt
kommt die zurück und das können wir
nicht zulassen Herr Frost sind sie auch
wieder Stoppschild
ich bin tatsächlich ein bisschen
bei Frau Weinfeld und ich finde auch so
die Aussagen von der Bohlen sollte man
jetzt nicht auf die Goldwaage legen er
redet halt wie in der Mund gewachsen ist
und ich glaube Herr Bohlen sagt eben das
was viele ich zum Beispiel auch und
viele aus der gesellschaftlichen Mitte
glaube ich befürchten dass die ganze
Sache einfach sich immer weiter zuspitzt
und
gefühlt hört man natürlich eine Position
ich gefühlt höre die Position
Waffenlieferungen Waffen lief morgen
Waffenlieferung
die Wirtschaft Sanktionen ja auch weiß
ich nicht das kann ich ganz schwer
bewerten ne inwieweit sowas greift aber
ich würde es auch schön finden wenn man
auch noch mal sich überlegt ob man sich
dann nicht an Tisch setzen kann
tatsächlich für mich gefühlt spitzt sich
das auch
sehr hart zu und man hört halt immer wir
müssen mehr Waffen liefern ich weiß
nicht ob das der richtige Weg ist weil
natürlich mehr Waffen aus meiner Sicht
verlängern den Krieg und damit auch so
das Leid der Menschen also wenn ich
zusammenfasse haben Sie eigentlich Angst
dass Deutschland jetzt aktiver
Teilnehmer hineingezogen wird
also ich bin überzeugt dass sie mir den
Faktor schon wenn wir auch gerade auf
Cyberattacken gucken dann sind wir aktiv
beteiligt und ich als ganz normaler sind
wir beteiligt was Cyberattacken betrifft
es gibt und und gab viele
seilbahnattacken auch auf öffentliche
Einrichtungen das Fraunhofer Institut
war vor kurzem Thema Verwaltungen und
ich bin mir sicher dass ich das auch
immer zuspitzen wird tatsächlich
und auch wenn ihr über Waffenlieferungen
reden finde ich
ist ist man natürlich beteiligt
automatisch
dann ist nicht Kriegsparteien nur weil
man Waffen liefert aber ich weiß was er
meint aber ja man spricht das nicht aus
aber natürlich
unterstützt man damit den Krieg auch
finde ich also ich habe so ein bisschen
so ein bisschen Sorge dass mehr Waffen
auch mehr Leid bedeuten hier würde ich
einmal ganz gerne kurz eine kurze
Einschätzung noch mal vom paar ranzhalle
haben weil das beschäftigt wirklich und
da haben sie vollkommen Recht ganz viele
Menschen in diesem Land wie ob es
möglich ist wie es möglichst Putin an
den Tisch zu bekommen und wenn man hört
einfach ein Tisch setzen ist es denn
überhaupt möglich Paul wie sieht es da
aus
also erstmal muss ich noch einmal ganz
kurz sagen es ist das Gegenteil ist hier
der Fall in der Ukraine
die Waffen die wir liefern sorgen für
weniger Leid insbesondere was eben die
Zivilisten angeht in diesem Raum in den
ich war im Osten des Landes in anderen
Teilen des Landes die befreit werden die
befreit werden von Russland die diese
Menschen terrorisieren die diese
Menschen und die ukrainische Kultur
zerstören wollen und das teilweise tun
da findet eine Befreiung statt und da
kann man nicht sagen weil wir den Waffen
liefern wird es da schlimmer nein in den
Regionen gerade was auch die deutschen
Waffen angeht nämlich die
Luftverteidigung zum Beispiel die
eingesetzt wird um russische Raketen
abzufangen das bedeutet dass es weniger
Leid gibt hier in der Ukraine das ist
mir ganz wichtig zu sagen was
Verhandlungen angeht man muss das auch
immer wieder ganz klar machen würde mir
selenski war von Anfang an das Krieges
und vor dem Krieg immer
mit Wladimir Putin zu sprechen aber was
jetzt passiert ist in den vergangenen
drei Wochen in den vergangenen Monaten
erstens klare Kriegsverbrechen zweitens
gab es die Fake Referenten wladimir
Putin hat gesagt ja diese Regionen die
gehören jetzt Russland und darüber ist
auch nicht mehr zu reden und er hat dann
eine nuklear Drohung ausgesprochen wenn
es zu einem Erfolg führt das Vladimir
Putin mit diesen Drohungen und diesen
Äußerungen dann sagt okay ich kriege das
was ich will und da gebe ich dann Herrn
felgentor recht dann bedeutet das auch
eine Gefahr für die gesamte Weltordnung
denn das würde bedeuten ein Land wie
Russland kann ein anderes erpressen und
bekommt dann das was es will momentan
ist die Lage so dass die Ukraine ganz
unabhängig von den Raketen Angriffen die
es auf Kiew gab und andere Städte gab an
der Front gewinnt da gab es
Gebietsgewinne die immens sind in den
vergangenen Monaten Dinge die man der
Ukraine nicht zugetraut hat und die
Ukraine souveräner Staat sagt wir werden
es dann verhandeln wenn die russischen
Truppen aus dem Land sind und
mittlerweile sagt man auch erst dann
wenn es einen neuen Präsidenten gibt
wenn Wladimir Putin dort nicht mehr ist
da weiß ich nicht ob das so schlau ist
dass sozusagen da bin ich in different
allerdings verstehe ich es dass ein Land
sagt nein wir sind nicht bereit Teile
unseres Landes Orte den Russen zu
überlassen das wäre so als würde ein
fremdes Land Deutschland überfallen und
wir sagen okay Stuttgart und München
sind vielleicht doch nicht ganz so
wichtig die bekommt dann dieses Land das
ist die Realität
danke für deine Einschätzung Paul wir
kommen jetzt zu der These von ihnen Frau
weidenfell heute abend
erstmal Antworten zu sagen militärisch
zu äußern obwohl ich das überhaupt nicht
vorhatte von wegen ja
Verhandlungsbereitschaft es geht ja so
ein Gerücht jetzt kam es ja gerade
wieder vor von einem Experten das ist ja
durchaus Pläne gab im April ein
Vorschlag und angeblich soll also
Johnson herein gestürmt sein vielleicht
weiß es noch der expendé aus
geheimquellen und gesagt jetzt ist nicht
die Zeit wir Verhandlungen ja also
erstmal ist die Frage wer verhandelt ist
es die Ukraine oder ziehen da
möglicherweise die USA im Hintergrund
die Strippen dass wir die eine Frage die
ich gern Paul zurückgeben möchte und das
andere ist
ja ist die Ukraine wirklich so
verhandlungsbereit also
tut mir leid diese Logik mehr Waffen
weniger leid
vielleicht bin ich alles
Kulturwissenschaftlerin da einfach zu
blöd also kapiere es nicht also selensky
hat ja mal gesagt vor einigen Monaten
ich will keine Rückeroberung der Krim
das würde 100.000 Tote bedeuten
ja geben wir also die beiden Fragen
einfach mal direkt dann
zurückgeschaltet ja also ich kann es
ganz praktisch ganz praktisch erklären
mehr Waffen weniger Leid warum wenn es
die Luftverteidigung Irish t die zum
Beispiel gerade geliefert wurde von
Deutschland hier in Kiew schon gegeben
hätte
wäre Oksana nicht gestorben wäre Oksana
nicht von dieser Rakete getroffen worden
und ihr kleiner Sohn hätte noch eine
Mutter so klar und deutlich kann man das
beantworten
darf das erinnert mich so ein bisschen
an Trump wissen Sie wie der
schulvorfall war wo ein Attentäter in
der Schule über zehn Kinder erschossen
hatte hat Trump gesagt hätten wir die
Lehrer alle bewaffnet wäre das nicht
passiert
das ist eine Logik dürfen wir nicht
akzeptieren die dürfen wir nicht
akzeptieren herunter sondern unser Ziel
muss sein auch ohne Waffenlieferung
Frieden hat
Menschen gerettet hätte sorry das ist
doch absurd
wenn man hier eine Luftverteidigung
aufgebaut hätte seit vielen Wochen und
Monaten dann hätten diese Raketen diese
Menschen nicht getroffen so einfach ist
die Wahrheit und kommen Sie mir doch
damit nicht mit Donald Trump was hat das
denn mit Donald Trump zu tun
das hat nichts mit Donald Trump zu tun
sondern es hat mit der Logik der
Argumentation zu tun Waffen sind keine
Frieden stiftende Aktion und es gibt
auch nicht den Kontakt
natürlich
aber das ist ja genau das was ich so man
nimmt jetzt ein eine Aussage von Dieter
Bohlen die übrigens glaube ich wirklich
widerspiegelt was viele denken und
interpretiert da jetzt so mega viel rein
es gibt irgendwie gefühlt aus der Mitte
gibt es zwei Positionen Waffen
Friedensverhandlungen aber es gibt ja
noch viel dazwischen was da irgendwie
machen kann und das finde ich ein
bisschen schade dass also ich habe das
Gefühl es sind so zwei ganz verhärtete
Fronten ich möchte gerne einmal noch
ganz kurz dabei bleiben bei der bei der
Sache die paronsheim erklärt hat und
wohin andere Meinung war Herr Felgentreu
als ehemaliger Sprecher ja
wie sehen Sie das denn also was Herr
ronsheimer gerade erklärt hat da müssen
wir schon einmal bei bleiben weil er
hier große Unterschiede da in der in der
Log Auferstehung herrschen wie würden
sie es denn einschätzen
die Ukraine hat die Wahl sich zu
verteidigen das kann sie nur wenn wir
ihr die Waffen dafür geben denn die
ukrainische Rüstungsindustrie ist
größter größtenteils durch russische
Raketenangriffe zerstört worden und sie
war auch nie so stark dass sie alleine
in der Lage gewesen wäre diese
verteidigungsanstrengung zu tragen aber
wenn wir ihr die Waffen nicht geben dann
bleibt der Ukraine nur die Erfüllung der
russischen Kriegsziele das heißt es gibt
dann zwar eine Art von Frieden aber das
wäre natürlich eine Friedhofsruhe in der
Ukraine ist würde dann diese freie
russische diese freie ukrainische
Regierung nicht mehr geben man hätte
dann entweder eine Ukraine als besetzten
basalenstadt der Russen oder gar keine
Ukraine mehr das wäre die Alternative
und es gab doch am Anfang etliche
Experten die gesagt haben Russland nimmt
Kiew und die Ukraine in wenigen Tagen
ein oder nicht ja ich habe das immer für
etwas naiv gehalten ich bin seit 2013
der für den Bereich der ehemaligen
Sowjetunion zuständige Berichterstatter
in der SPD-Fraktion im
Verteidigungsausschuss gewesen bin also
mehrfach in die Region gereist und habe
beobachtet wie sich die Kampfkraft und
die Moral ukrainischen Streitkräfte
verändert hatte in den letzten acht
Jahren deswegen war mir relativ klar
dass die ein wesentlich unangenehmerer
Gegner für die Russen werden würden als
das so Land dort landläufig verbreitet
waren das allerdings die Russen so
schwach sein würden mit ihrem Angriff
das habe ich auch nicht erwartet nur
dieses dieses Szenario in drei Tagen
sind wir in Kiew das habe ich immer für
naiv gehalten also ich glaube ein
basalen Sieg will ja niemand und es war
sicherlich auch richtig zu Beginn auch
zu helfen aber die Frage ist wie geht es
jetzt weiter ja also ich glaube diese
verhärteten Positionen von denen sie
sprechen das sollen wir auch hier auch
zusammenfinden also mir fiel ein wenn
ich noch mal das ist schon diese
Extremposition das ist so ein Stichwort
für mich in der corona-krise hieß es
jedes Menschenleben aus Corona zum Opfer
fällt ist eins zu viel Freiheit ist
nichts
Leben ist alles und jetzt haben wir
genau den das Gegenteil das Leben ist
nichts hunderttausend die sterben müssen
egal es geht um die Freiheit und ich
würde sagen wie sie die die Wahrheit
zwischen ja Verteidigung ja klar
natürlich helfen wir natürlich ist
Russland der böse Aggressor ja
aber die Wahrheit liegt dazwischen wann
ist es Zeit mal an den Verhandlungstisch
zu gehen und Frieden und Verhandlungen
im Vordergrund zurück
hier ist ja das Problem dass viele sagen
es gibt keinen möglichen
Verhandlungstisch also das ist ja immer
dass das gegen der Gegenpunkt der kommt
dass es nicht möglich ist mit Putin zu
verhandeln aber darüber haben sie ja
auch den Beitrag geschrieben zum
Beispiel in der Süddeutschen Zeitung
dass sie eher empfinden das auch eine
gewisse Kriegslust herrscht also beiden
hat ja heute auch positive Signale dazu
geäußert also ich bin jetzt heute wieder
ganz optimistisch gesehen ja aber zurück
zu meiner These ja die intelle ja also
das ist mein Milieu über das ich spreche
dass mich auch persönlich wirklich
enttäuscht hat nicht alle intellektuell
ich will jetzt keine intellektuellen
Bashing machen aber es ist doch eine
mächtige Gruppe und wir schauen zurück
in die Geschichte gut es wird immer vom
Ersten Weltkrieg erzählt es wurde auch
von Historikern aufgearbeitet das
Künstler denke intellektuelle da eine
negative Rolle gespielt haben und sich
haben verleiten lassen in den 68ern war
das auch da ist eine gute Idee die aber
dann verhärtet irgendwann zu einer
Ideologie wird man kann sich fragen
warum ist es so
ist es dass das auch nie die Langeweile
des das geschützten Lebens man sehnt
sich nach dem echten Leben oder ist es
gar eine Krise der Männlichkeit
wäre vielleicht auch möglich in den
westlichen Staaten die dann dazu
verleitet dass man gewisse Dinge sehr
idealisiert auch die Ukraine nicht als
topografische Ort der angegriffen wird
aber als Ort wir haben es gerade gehört
der Demokratie ich meine das Ranking war
jetzt nicht ideal ja damit will ich
nicht sagen dass Russland dass du
irgendwas in irgendeiner Weise
rechtfertigt ist aber wir dürfen auch
nicht idealisieren der Ukraine hat sich
ja in den letzten Jahren aber auch viel
verändert wenn man auch mit Blick auf
die Demokratie schaut die die Frage die
ich mir gestellt habe Frau Weinfeld ich
habe ihr ich habe das mit sehr großen
Interesse gelesen sollten sich denn
überhaupt Intellektuelle zum Krieg
äußern das war meine Frage erstmal und
dann habe ich gedacht vielleicht haben
diese Intellektuellen auch keine
Kriegslust sondern einfach Bewunderung
empfunden für Menschen die ihr Land
verteidigen für Frauen das war auch ein
Beispiel die an die Front gehen weil sie
in Freiheit leben wollen vielleicht ist
es auch einfach Bewunderung habe ich
gedacht ja wobei ich dann wieder zu dem
zurückkehre was ich eben gesagt habe
Freiheit ist wichtig ja natürlich aber
sind wir dafür bereit ja breit und Leben
wirklich alles geben ja ist alternative
ich rede nicht von alternativen ich rede
von dem dazwischen jagenfreiheit oder
leben das ist die falsche Alternative
die Toten von Butcher die haben mit
ihrer Freiheit auch ihr Leben verloren
und das gilt für Hunderttausende für
Millionen in den heute besetzten
Gebieten ganz genauso dass die von genau
dieser Art von Vernichtung von Tod
bedroht sind von Vertreibung und von
Ermordung davon von der Entführung ihrer
Kinder all diese Dinge passieren dafür
da sind Freiheit und leben Synonyme
haben
das Andere entscheiden der Sicherheit
immer weitermachen genau deswegen sie
wollen das Morgen nicht dich auch nicht
der Krieg ist das schlimmste was
passieren kann wir sehen es ja gerade
deswegen es kann nicht sein dass der
einzige Weg ist zu sagen kann ich mit
Putin verhandeln es geht nicht es geht
nicht anscheinend geht es doch es kommen
hoffnungsvolle Signale aus den USA heute
ja und dann scheint wenn man den
Gerüchten glaubt das sind jetzt die
Quellen Wale ja auch schon mal was ja
das muss in den Fokus rücken Paul du
bist uns ja auch noch zugeschaltet den
Text kennst du wahrscheinlich aber was
ich besonders hier finde einen Tisch ist
zeigt schon sehr klar die Stimmung in
diesem Land in Deutschland auf es wurde
gerade gesagt es gibt hoffnungsvolle
Anzeichen für Verhandlungen wie nimmst
du das wahr
ich sehe diese hoffnungsvollen Anzeichen
nicht zumindest nicht hier in der
Ukraine da ist man fest gewillt zu sagen
wir holen uns unser Land weiter zurück
noch einmal
er fällt heute das ja gerade klar
gemacht es geht nicht darum ob hier
irgendjemand für ein Freiheitskampf
gefeiert wird sondern diejenigen die
dort kämpfen kämpfen für ihre
Mitmenschen um sie zu befreien um sie zu
retten um dafür zu sorgen dass diese
horror-taten die in diesem Bild die in
diesem Gebieten passieren aufhören das
ist der Grund warum die Ukraine kämpft
und ihr Land
zurückerobern will und das hat nichts
mit dem einen Sinne da ist irgendetwas
heroisches zu dem jetzt intellektuelle
aufschauen und auf der anderen Seite
sind die Soldaten nein das ist der
völlig falsche Ansatz was Verhandlungen
angeht ja es gab am Anfang haben zu
Beginn des Krieges diese Versuche
dann passierten Dinge wie in Butcher
dann passiert in weitere
Kriegsverbrechen dann hat hatte ich mir
Putin gesagt das sind jetzt meine
Gebiete das ist jetzt mein Russland also
hat illegale Referenten dort stattfinden
lassen so unter welchen Voraussetzungen
soll denn würde mir selenski sich mit
Wladimir Putin momentan an einen Tisch
setzen das funktioniert nicht es
funktioniert auch nicht innerhalb der
Ukraine weil die Ukraine dann gegen
selensky wahrscheinlich Aufstehen würden
und sagen moment mal es sind so viele
Menschen gestorben
wir wollen dass dieses Land unseres
bleibt befreit bleibt und dann die
zweite ganz ganz wichtige Sache bei der
Frage der Verhandlung und was ein Grund
ist warum die Ukraine sagt wir müssen
diesen Krieg gewinnen und wir müssen
diesen Krieg zu Ende führen der Krieg
hat ja schon mal begonnen 2014 eben im
Ostteil des Landes und wir haben dann
erlebt dass Russland immer weiter
gemacht hat und die große Sorge der
Ukraine ist und ich glaube die ist sehr
berechtigt ähm wenn man jetzt eine Art
Waffenstillstand machen würde jetzt
ausgerechnet jetzt wo die Ukraine
sozusagen am Vorteil sind im Osten und
im Süden dann würde Russland sich weiter
bewaffnen würde sozusagen die
militärproduktion weiter auffahren würde
eine Mobilisierung professioneller
hinbekommen und das würde bedeuten in
wenigen Monaten oder auch einem Jahr
würde man wieder versuchen Kiew
anzugreifen es ist ja nicht so dass ich
putinsil verändern würde weil es ist im
putin ist kein Verhandlungspartner er
hat alles gebrochen er hat vor dem Krieg
gesagt er wird die Ukraine nicht
angreifen er hat Versprechungen gemacht
er hat gelogen er hat all das getan
weshalb man sagen muss selbst wenn er
jetzt sagen würde wir setzen uns
gemeinsam hin und wir wir versuchen
jetzt hier eine Lösung zu finden das
würde bedeuten die Ukraine Wissen in
wenigen Monaten greift er wieder an ja
es hat hier auch eigentlich noch jemand
die dieselbe these mit dessen sehr
felgentreuer weil sie sagen ja auch
Russland Schwächen und dass ihre These
heute Abend dieses Völkerrecht wieder
Stärken des Völkerrecht wieder
aufrichten dafür sorgen dass ein Land
das ein anderes mit einem Angriffskrieg
überzieht und in dem Moment in dem es
auf dem Schlachtfeld ins Hintertreffen
gerät sagt wenn ihr uns jetzt weiter
bedroht dann dann bekämpfen wir euch mit
Atomwaffen dass ein Land mit so einer
Strategie nicht durchkommt weil ich die
Sorge habe dass das unsere ganze Welt
überall sehr viel unsicherer machen wird
das werden sehr viele Leute
entsprechende lernen daraus ziehen und
das darf nicht geschehen deswegen muss
diese Angriffskrieg scheitern und
scheitern heißt es dürfen keine
territorialen Gewinne daraus erwachsen
dass der der große Punkt der ganz viele
Menschen in diesem Land auch umtreibt
übrigens inklusive Mia sind die
Wirtschaftssanktionen und zwar auch ob
die überhaupt greifen alle und ob sie
genug überprüft werden wie ist denn da
zu ihre Meinung jetzt nehmen wir mal
nicht die Waffenlieferung sondern als
Thema die Wirtschaftssanktionen wirklich
greifen die alle und hat die Regierung
da wirklich einen guten Job gemacht ja
also ich bin da ziemlich sicher dass die
Wirtschaftssanktionen greifen sie
greifen alle sie greifen nicht alle
gleich gut ja es gibt also
umgehungstatbestände beispielsweise wenn
man sich die die Sanktionen auf
Ölimporte anguckt dann gelingt es
Russland über Importe nach Indien einen
Teil davon zu umgehen aber insgesamt
greifen diese wirtschaftsaktionen sie
haben die Lebenswirklichkeit in Russland
bereits massiv verändert und ich kommt
auch bei den Menschen in Russland an
dass sie im Krieg sind das versucht ihre
Regierung ja in sie davon zu überzeugen
dass das gar nicht der Fall wäre auch
das ist glaube ich ein wichtiger Faktor
für die öffentliche Meinung für die
Diskussionen Russland geführt werden
aber sie schwächen vor allen Dingen auch
die russische Industrie insbesondere die
russische Rüstungsindustrie und deswegen
ist es sehr gut dass es diese Sanktionen
gibt wo man sie noch verschaffen kann
sollte man das tun sie wird noch weiter
verschärfen da wo das möglich ist oder
sinnvoll möglich ist sollte man das tun
ja
Standpunkt dazu zum wirtschaftssanktion
ich würde gerne nochmal beginnen was der
Felgentreu dargelegt hat die die globale
Welt also die Welt war schon unsicher
vor der ukraine-krise und die These mit
der Ukraine Krise und wenn Russland wie
auch immer irgendeinen Gewinn zieht wird
das ganze noch viel schlimmer diese
These teile ich nicht es ist auch nicht
so was eben mir gesagt worden ist alle
Diktatoren der Welt würden sich das zum
Beispiel nehmen ich brauche einen
Diktator kein Beispiel zu geben wir
Unrecht in der Welt verbreitet und wir
Menschen tötet das Wissen diese
Kriminellen alleine und das Bauen die
sich nicht vom Putin oder anderen
Diktatoren anzuschauen da gibt es in der
Geschichte Beispiele zu Hauff
wir müssen uns auf die auf die Ukraine
konzentrieren also es ist keine
Blaupause für andere Diktatoren
beispielsweise
jeder Konflikt ist anders also gibt es
irgendeinen Konflikt der eine Blaupause
für einen anderen Konflikt war schon die
Weltkriege haben sich unterschieden die
einzelnen Konflikte sie je nach Region
sind unterschiedlich also zu glauben da
gibt es jetzt eine ein Exportmodell wie
greife ich meinen Nachbarn an und wie
gewinne ich also das ist nur wirklich
herbeigeredet das ist jetzt etwas
flapsig formuliert das ist natürlich
ihnen zuzugestehen aber man könnte ja
schon sagen wenn dann Putin bemerkt okay
der besten reagiert eigentlich nicht
wirklich wie beispielsweise bei der
Annexion der Krim das kann man ja
eigentlich jetzt schon als Blaupause
sehen dass er sich gedacht hat dass man
weitermachen kann oder nicht nee das
kann man nicht so als Blaupause sehen
weil die Annexion der Krim hat der
Westen aus meiner Sicht gar nicht so
falsch reagiert sondern wir haben ja
Verhandlungen geführt wir haben auch bei
der Destabilisierung der Ostukraine
Verhandlung geführt ich fand Ergebnisse
im Minsk Format gut im Übrigen hat sich
die Ukraine in vielen Punkten nicht an
diese Verhandlungsergebnisse gehalten
das muss auch mal zur Wahrheit gesagt
werden sondern der Westen hat schon aus
seiner Sicht vernünftig reagiert dass
man gegen jemanden der plötzlich alle
Regeln bricht und mit Gewalt die Welt zu
verändern versucht als als
moralisch werteorientierte Gemeinschaft
erst mal ein Stück zurückziehen muss und
überlegen muss wie reagieren wir denn
das versteht sich schon selbst das sieht
man im ersten Moment nicht ganz gut aus
aber im zweiten Moment glaube ich haben
wir uns noch ganz gut gefangen einmal
mit den Waffenlieferungen dafür bin ich
wir müssen den heldenlieferungen wir
müssen den heldenhaften Kampf dieses
ukrainischen Volkes unterstützen völlig
klar ich bin auch für Sanktionen weil
das ist im Grunde genommen nur noch das
einzige Mittel was wir neben den
Waffenlieferungen haben denn alles
andere ist ja schon längst gescheitert
nicht durch den Russland Konflikt
sondern die Entwicklung wer nimmt den VN
Sicherheitsrat noch ernst schon vor dem
Konflikt niemand wer nimmt die VN
Vollversammlung noch ernst schon vor dem
Konflikt niemand wer nimmt
internationale Gerichtshilfe noch ernst
schon vor dem Konflikt niemand das heißt
also wir haben unsere
konfliktmechanismen schon längst
verloren dass es übrigens ein Thema wo
wir immer dringend ran müssen wenn wir
das hier mal gelöst haben und da bleiben
uns nur Waffenlieferungen und es bleiben
uns nur Sanktionen über einzelne
sinnvolle Sanktionen muss man noch mal
diskutieren und ich fand die das
Beispiel von ronsheimer ganz gut dass
man die Hochtechnologie der Russen
abschneidet und sie damit in ihre
Rüstungsindustrie empfindlich getroffen
werden dass es nun ganz gelungener Kuh
des Westens so aber
dass alle die und ich komme noch mal auf
die These zurück das alle die die hier
Hurra schreien und sagen also die Russen
dürfen nicht gewinnen dass alle die die
sagen wir dürfen uns nicht erpressen
lassen dass alle die die sagen also
jetzt müssen wir aber mal und so weiter
dass mir da einfach der Plan fehlt mit
mir fehlt die Lösung ich bin dafür dass
wir den Russen zeigen was eine Harke ist
ich bin dafür dass wir nicht dulden was
ein Angriffskrieg ist aber mir fehlt der
Plan wie soll das am Ende aussehen wenn
wir Sanktionen machen wenn wir Waffen
liefern und uns dann zurücksetzen und
sagen das wird ja wohl irgendwie alles
gut gehen das geht nicht das ist nicht
unsere Verantwortung wir müssen eine
aktive Friedenspolitik betreiben und
dazu gehört dass wir erstens erster
Schritt Waffenstillstand zweiter Schritt
Verhandlungen wie kommen wir mit den
Russen klein und all ihre Argumente die
wollen wir uns nach einer kurz
Unterbrechung anderen jetzt noch einmal
zurück zu meinem Kollegen pauronsheimer
der nach der Unterbrechung nämlich
leider nicht mehr bei uns sein kann
paula ist nur etwas abschließendes für
die Runde mitzuteilen
ich glaube dass man mehr an die Ukraine
glauben sollte und dass viele geglaubt
haben dass die Ukraine Kia verlieren
würde dass sie den Donbass schnell
verlieren würden die Wahrheit ist
momentan gewinnt die Ukraine ich glaube
das sollten sich alle die verinnerlichen
die immer glauben dass Russland
militärisch nicht zu schlagen ist
Russland wird momentan militärisch im
Osten und Süden geschlagen
eine letzte Frage habe ich doch noch
Paul mir ist eingefallen Wladimir
Klitschko hat ihr heute auch eine
Einladung an Bowlen ausgesprochen ist
dieser der denn schon gefolgt
ich habe mit Dieter Bohlen keinen
Kontakt von daher weiß ich das nicht er
hat sich noch nicht geäußert dazu ich
glaube das tatsächlich was Wladimir
Klitschko und andere machen in der
Ukraine tatsächlich ein ein gutes
Beispiel dafür ist ja es ist jemand der
sagt schaut euch das selbst an und ich
glaube auch an einige in der Runde
schaut euch an was in Orten wie in
Butcher und anderen passiert ist es
etwas anderes ob man das im Fernsehen
sieht oder ob man wenn man dann als
Experte im TV ist oder Gastbeiträge
schreibt oder was auch immer tut sollte
man in der Ukraine gewesen sein vielen
herzlichen Dank paar vor allem auch für
deinen Einsatz und pass gut auf Dich auf
wir hören uns bald wieder und wir sehen
uns gleich wieder nach einer kurzen
Unterbrechung
[Musik]
ernst nehmen als sogenannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach fünf Köpfe fünf
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi der Wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz anders
also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken ich habe meinen
Beifall in meine lache immer bekommen
wer kümmert sich darum niemand bitte
ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal auch
darüber sprechen dass es einfach nicht
fair ist und nicht richtig Aufgabe von
Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir machen weiter und wir wollen keine
Zeit verlieren und kommen direkt zu
Herrn schindler
wir sind bei ihnen und ihrer These was
sie uns heute Abend mitgebracht haben
was sie heute bewegt ja mich bewegt
einerseits ich will noch mal darauf
aufmerksam machen dass kriegerische
Auseinandersetzungen nicht nur die
Stunde von Militär sind oder von
Politikern sondern auch die Stunde der
Nachrichtendienste Nachrichtendienst zu
bringen die Informationen die man
braucht auf dem Gefechtsfeld aber auch
für die Diplomatie oder für den
Informationskrieg und Nachrichtendienste
halten auch Kontakte für Verhandlungen
und Verhandlung ist mein Stichwort für
die Ukraine ich glaube wir müssen
einfach feststellen dieser Krieg
eskaliert in vielen kleinen Schritten
wenn wir uns zurückschauen wie hat er
begonnen und wo stehen wir heute wie hat
sich das ausgeweitet und das will ich
gar nicht nur an den Waffenlieferungen
festmachen sondern insgesamt wie hat
sich das ausgeweitet dann stellen wir
fest stetig aber sicher eskaliert dieser
Konflikt und dann stellt sich die Frage
wie soll er denn Enden ich kenne kein
vernünftiges Szenario wie dieser Krieg
beendet werden kann für mich ist
jedenfalls kein vernünftiges Szenario
dass er militärisch beendet wird mit der
Niederlage des ein oder mit der
Niederlage des anderen eine Niederlage
der Russen würden die Russen so nicht
hinnehmen und da bin ich ganz sicher bei
ronsheimer da haben wir die große Gefahr
des Einsatzes einer Atomwaffe einer
taktischen Atomwaffe eine Niederlage der
Ukraine wollen wir nicht hinnehmen und
wir haben die große Gefahr wie reagiert
der Westen wird er noch mehr
hineingezogen ich bin der Meinung wir
dürfen uns von der Ukraine nicht
instrumentalisieren lassen die Ukraine
hat das große Ziel zu gewinnen das
verstehe ich ich will sie auch
unterstützen aber sie hat auch das Ziel
den Westen mit hineinzuziehen weil das
viel besser für die Ausgangsposition ist
dann müssen wir ehrlich aufpassen und
wenn wir etwas machen wollen dann glaube
ich ist es jetzt aktiv dafür einzutreten
dass es einen Waffenstillstand gibt
einen Waffenstillstand der die Basis für
Verhandlungen ist und Verhandlungen kann
man sich viele vielfach vorstellen ich
bin ganz sicher die Russen werden
verhandeln wollen und ich bin noch ganz
sicher bei nötigem Druck in die Ukrainer
verhandeln wollen und wie eine solche
Verhandlungslösung aussieht dann können
wir uns ja gleich mal drüber unterhalten
aber ich habe
ich als Bürgerin am Anfang ihrer These
mit Blick auf den
Bundesnachrichtendienst kann es denn
sein dass schon Gespräche oder
Informationen hinter den Kulissen laufen
und man schon näher an Verhandlungen ist
als wie das wissen also die
Nachrichtendienste verhandeln in solchen
Fragen nicht sondern die schaffen die
schaffen die Basis zu Verhandlung zu
Verhandlungen führen ja sie halten die
den Kontakte weil sie sagen lass uns mal
treffen wenn jetzt unsere Politiker sich
austauschen wollen ohne dass sie es über
die Bild-Zeitung machen wollen sondern
in Geheimverhandlungen und dann muss das
ja irgendwie organisiert werden das ist
die Stunde der Nachrichtendienste und da
könnte auch schon viele Bewegungen sein
das könnte uns Herr Felgen treu am
besten darlegen also
da frage ich sie ist natürlich Herr
Felgentreu wissen vielleicht die
Nachrichtendienste teilweise mehr als
die Politiker
das will ich schwer hoffen also
jedenfalls habe ich für mich als in
meiner Rolle als als
Verteidigungspolitiker Informationen
brauchte mich an die Nachrichtendienste
gewandt in der Hoffnung sie dort zu
finden ja ich kann jetzt nicht über
alles berichten was ich dadurch auf
diesem Wege erfahren habe aber ich gehe
schon davon aus dass die
Nachrichtendienste werden zumindest mehr
wissen als
die die die die durchschnittlichen
Abgeordneten des Bundestages und so
sollte es auch sein und man sollte dann
eben als Abgeordneter versuchen diese
Informationen abzurufen damit man
tragfähige politische Entscheidungen
treffen kann ja aber was Schindler was
Sie gesagt haben ich sehe dann
Widerspruch in sich wenn sie sagen sie
wollen einerseits nicht die Niederlage
Russland sie wollen aber andererseits
auch nicht die Niederlage der Ukraine
bzw wieder den Sieg der einen auf der
anderen Seite und deswegen wollen sie
jetzt einen Waffenstillstand aus meiner
Sicht ist vollkommen klar ein
Waffenstillstand jetzt ist ein
Etappensieg im Rahmen einer Salamitaktik
der russischen Seite der erste dieser
Krieg begann nicht im Februar 2022 er
begann im März glaube ich 2014 damals
wurde die erste Scheibe von der Salami
abgeschnitten nämlich der Don Bass und
die und die Krim und wenn wir jetzt
einen Waffenstillstand hätten dann
hätten wir die zweite Scheibe von der
Salami und zwar eine ziemlich dicke
Scheibe und das wäre bloß das
Aufmarschgebiet um dann die dritte
Scheibe Angriff zu nehmen mir wäre das
nicht mehr erreichen Sie durch einen
Waffenstillstand heute als der Ukraine
militärisch ganz schlecht ging in der
Anfangsphase war die Ukraine doch bereit
ein Waffenstillstand zu schließen so und
jetzt ist die Ukraine militärisch gut
dabei also sie Obsidian und dem im
Norden dann geht plötzlich ein
Waffenstillstand nicht also diesen
Widerspruch den sehe ich allerdings auch
und ich glaube
wenn wir eine Güte Abwägung machen
Salami Taktik russischer Sieg tappensieg
und auf der anderen Seite sehen wie
viele Menschen kommen tagtäglich in der
Ukraine um wie viel Leid bringt jeden
Tag dieser Krieg und das nicht nur für
die Ukraine sondern jetzt manchmal das
große Fass auf für die gesamte Welt die
Weltwirtschaft leidet darunter nicht nur
unter den Sanktionen sondern insgesamt
ist ja das ganze runterfahren der
Weltwirtschaft ursprünglich auch auf
diesen Ukraine Krieg zurückzuführen die
Migrationsfrage habe ich noch gar nicht
gestellt und und das ist ja ein eine
scharniert sind mehr Menschen gekommen
als 2015 also das bedeutet doch zu sagen
wir können den Russen keinen Etappen sie
gönnen und lassen aber zu dass alles
dieses Elend und dieses Unrecht was
geschieht weil Tag für Tag weiterläuft
das finde ich und da bin ich bei ihrer
These das finde ich so erschreckend für
Deutschland wo wir doch früher uns mal
so
Friedenspolitik empfunden haben und da
frage ich mich was ist in dieser
Gesellschaft passiert dass wir plötzlich
diesen Polizisten
weil ich muss noch verdauen was du
heranzheimer gesagt hat und ich glaube
genau das ist nämlich das Problem wenn
jemand sagt okay
lasst uns doch noch mal reden wird es
kategorisch ausgeschlossen und die
Antwort ist ihr müsst hierher kommen das
Leid ziehen darum geht es doch gar nicht
ne also das ist das Schlimmste ist
kategorisch ausgeschlossen er hat gesagt
sie müssen sie müssen nicht im Studio
sitzen und hier vorbeikommen und das
leidchen also dass das was ich
verstanden habe jetzt am Ende noch er
kann sie jetzt nicht werden konnte ich
auch nicht weil die Pause gegangen sind
aber ich finde das zeigt so ein bisschen
das Problem dass die Fronten sehr
verhärtet sind und und dass da teilweise
argumentativ ja gar nicht mehr
diskutiert wird also es geht um uns ja
ums leid uns allen geht also zu sagen
wenn jetzt jemand sagt ich möchte das
Beenden auf welche Art auch immer
man möchte verhandeln zum Beispiel wenn
man dann sagt sie müssen hierher kommen
und das Leid ziehen darum geht's ja
nicht also
wir haben ihn nicht die Frage über
Verhandlungen gestellt und das war
darauf nicht seine Antwort sondern er
hatte generell gesprochen über wenn
jemand der eine Klone schreibt oder ein
Spezialist im Studio sitzt äh und sowas
von sich gibt dann müsste er darunter
kommen das habe ich tatsächlich schon so
verstanden nee es war auch nicht auf die
verhandlungsfrage aber jetzt da jetzt
können wir darüber auch nicht mit den
beiden jetzt nicht mehr dabei aber ich
würde sie gerne noch aussprechen lassen
weil sie wurden gerade nein ganz naive
Frage stellen ich bin
Kulturwissenschaftlerin ich kenne mich
auch nicht aus die sind ja ausgewiesen
Experte wenn also Verhandlungen
definitiv auszuschließen sind wenn wir
Russland nicht weiter die Salami
aufessen und aufschneiden lassen wollen
wie geht es denn weiter also wir hören
erst dann auf wenn Putin also ich frage
mich das wird Putin dann sagen wisst ihr
was okay ich ziehe mich zurück wie wie
geht es denn weiter mal ganz konkret
also die These dass eine macht wie
dieser Russland nicht in der einen Krieg
nicht verlieren kann ich weiß nicht
woher diese Erkenntnis kommt also ich
kann mich an den in den letzten zwei
Generationen an mehrere Kriege erinnern
die eine andere atomacht verloren hat
Vietnam
auch der Irak weil letztlich kein Sieg
ja also Atommächte können Kriege
verlieren das ist so und die Ukraine tut
im Moment nichts anderes sie ist an das
ist eine reiner Verteidigungskrieg den
die Ukraine führt denn die Befreiung von
besetzten Gebiet ist selbstverständlich
Verteidigung die auch keine greift da
nichts an sondern sie versucht lediglich
Land zu befreien und vor allen Dingen
Menschen zu befreien die im Moment unter
der Besatzungsmacht Leben und wenn sie
sagen jeden Tag sterben während der
Kampfhandlungen Menschen und durch die
Luftangriffe in den besetzten Gebieten
starben Menschen in Folterkellern
Menschen werden verschleppt also das
Leid wird nicht dadurch auf dass man
einen Waffenstillstand hat sondern die
ethnischen Säuberungen die
rustifizierung mit Gewalt der besetzten
Gebiete die gehen selbstverständlich mit
großen Schritten weiter und dann im
Schutz eines solchen Waffenstillstandes
deswegen dass die Ukraine kämpft das ist
erstens in der Sache legitim und
zweitens ist es auch aussichtsreich und
der Endpunkt nachdem immer gefragt hat
ist natürlich die Befreiung der
Besetzung
mit einem Gebiet jetzt vergleichen was
unmittelbar in Russland
kann kein Krieg verlieren
das wäre doch was ganz anderes die sind
unnötig mal dran die wollten das als
Pufferzone ich meine man muss schon die
Dinge irgendwie geopolitisch bringen
oder die wollten ihr Imperium wieder
aufrichten das wollen Sie immer noch
ganz klar
Station macht was sagt die NATO sagt
okay die größte Katastrophe des 20
Jahrhunderts war der war der Zerfall der
Sowjetunion und seine Politik ist darauf
gerichtet dass Territorium der
Sowjetunion als russisches Gebiet wieder
herzustellen deshalb machte an mehreren
Stellen klar gemacht das hat er auch
ganz klar gesagt unter handelt auch
politisch danach das kann man in vielen
Etappen nachweisen in seinem politischen
Werdegang in der Entwicklung seines
politischen Denkens und in den konkreten
Maßnahmen mit denen er das unterlegt das
ist eine sehr konsequent und stringente
Politik wir müssen ihn ernst nehmen aber
ihre Meinung und wenn wir in ernst
nehmen müssen müssen wir auch seine
Drogen ernst nehmen dass Atomwaffen nein
absolut
diese Ausgangslage
bin ich bisschen anderer Meinung zu Herr
Frost der macht sich nämlich auch noch
ganz andere Gedanken über unser Land und
zwar was die Cyberkriminalität genau
richtig ich sage bei uns in diesem Land
fehlt die Sensibilität gerade wenn es um
cyberkrang geht und auch ein Kontext des
ukrainekrieges tatsächlich und das ist
auch das was ich vorhin meinte wir sind
schon lange Partei weil auf dieser Ebene
natürlich auch in Deutschland
eindeutig ist Chile gibt und ich glaube
auch in der aktuellen Situation
Krieg Inflation höhere Armut steigt die
Gefahr dass in dem Bereich
Internetkriminalität immer mehr
passieren wird und ich glaube da haben
wir ein zu wenig offenes Ohr zu wenig
offene Augen tatsächlich sie waren ja
selbst cyberkrimineller wenn man das so
nennen kann
was haben sie genau selbst verbrochen
ich habe einen Marktplatz geleitet
zusammen mit zwei Mittätern in Darknet
es technisch ich erkläre das immer gerne
technisch technisch kann man das mit
E-Mail vergleichen nur das keine
Elektrogeräte gehandelt wurden sondern
Drogen und die waren die technischen
Vermittler sozusagen ja und wir wurden
2019 verhaftet ganz kurz wurden auch
verurteilt wir sind alle aktuell noch
draußen
und warten jetzt auf die Entscheidung
vom BGH und ich habe mich natürlich
nach der Verurteilung nach der Festnahme
sehr intensiv auch gerade mit den mit
der Thematik Cybercrime beschäftigt man
reflektiert was macht man da man kommt
auch mit Tätern ins Gespräch und auch
mit Opfern wenn ja kmues denken
Mittelständler fast jeder wurde schon
Opfer beraten wenn man selbst mal Täter
war ich glaube ja tatsächlich weil man
einen anderen Blickwinkel hat also ich
vergleiche das immer gerne mit mit einem
Trainer oder Strategie beim Fußball der
weiß natürlich theoretisch über die
Flanke schießt
aber er wird sich nicht so gut schießen
können wie ein Spieler und das ist eben
der Unterschied und ich glaube schon
und das ist ja auch mein Appell ich
glaube um Cybercrime kämpfen zu können
ist noch verstehen und man muss auch
verstehen wollen ich habe das Gefühl
hier in Deutschland bei Privathaushalten
genauso wie bei Firmen ist es irgendwie
gefühlt so dass wir jeden Tag mit Medien
umgehen mit IT-Systemen
und wir lassen die Türen auf also
Frage stellen
und alle Türen sind offen keiner zu
Hause so ist so gefühlt der Umgang wenn
man an seinem Security denkt kommt
Deutschland lahmlegen
weiß ich nicht also ich kann ein
Beispiel nennen
vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit wurde
die Universität in Düsseldorf glaube ich
Opfer eines Kitas Angriffs und es war
auch im Kontext ich meine es war
Düsseldorf
corona-zeiten Düsseldorf hat
Lernplattform bereitgestellt für
600 Schulen ungefähr im Bundesland es
gab ein videosangriff 600 Schulen waren
betroffen und das heißt die Schüler
konnten nicht lernen und dahinter ist
ein 14-jähriger Junge
wurde festgenommen und ermittelt und
was da eigentlich peinlich muss man
wirklich sagen es gibt viele weitere
vergleichbare sechsjährige sehr
intelligent 14 Jahre
tatsächlich
es gibt weitere Fälle wenn man ein
Rockstar Games denkt da gab es ein viele
die die GTA spielen werden das wissen da
gab es League uber wurde gehackt der
Täter war 17 Jahre alt
und das kann natürlich was im
persönlichen Bereich was man selber
immer macht ohne darüber nachzudenken
ich denke zum Beispiel ein
Online-Überweisungen wenn du darüber
sprechen denke ich so bin ich da
vielleicht etwas zu nachlässig ich
glaube es fängt schon viel vorher an und
das ja das Problem man kann ja natürlich
kann man überlegen ich stelle mir
it-sicherheitsberater ein machen viele
Firmen nicht weil zu teuer ist später
wird es dann teuer wenn es eine Menge
Attacke gibt aber das fängt ja viel
vorher an nämlich bei Menschen ja also
oft ist die Schwachstelle natürlich der
Mensch es gibt eine fishing E-Mail es
gibt einen Anhang jemand macht unbedacht
etwas auf und so werden dann komplet
Systeme verschlüsselt Krankenhäuser hat
mir in Deutschland auch schon
das Krankenhäuser
Opfer einer Salbe Attacke wurden und
dann auch tatsächlich die Ambulanzen
nicht mehr gelaufen sind
würde ich gerne mal Herr Schindler
Fragen ist denn dem der
Bundesnachrichtendienst weil man jetzt
daran liegt an ihre Zeit da ist der den
gut genug vorbereitet auf
Cyberkriminalität
also besser geht immer das ist klar und
gerade im Bereich IT glaube ich haben
alle Nachholbedarf jedenfalls diejenigen
Behörden die mit der cybersicherheit
befasst sind wir haben in Deutschland
große Probleme da stimme ich ihm zu wir
haben große Probleme einmal die
richtigen Leute zu finden die das
überhaupt in den Behörden machen können
weil die Behörden viel zu schlechter für
bezahlen und es ist schade dass er seine
Energie so gebraucht hat anstatt
beispielsweise beim
Bundesnachrichtendienst zu arbeiten wo
er bezahlt ist ja noch alles mögliche
hätte machen können also uns fehlen die
die richtigen Leute uns fehlen aber auch
die richtigen Eingriffsbefugnisse nur
zwei Beispiele also wenn beispielsweise
eine Firma eine Institution angegriffen
wird können wir heute nur zuschauen wir
sehen ah da kommt eine E-Mail und die
legt ihr den ganzen Laden lahm mehr
können wir nicht machen wir können das
System abschalten und können gucken dass
wir die E-Mail umleiten aber wir können
nicht beispielsweise im Sinne eines
heckbags zurückschicken auf den Server
nach Malaysia und sagen so jetzt machen
wir die mal kaputt damit der nicht mehr
diese E-Mail schickt dieses heckback ist
in Deutschland beispielsweise verboten
das dürfen die Behörden nicht die
Schweiz macht das schon seit 2016
erfolgreich niemand hat der Schweiz den
Krieg erklärt alles okay und so haben
wir beispielsweise demonstrantenschutz
in Deutschland die beispielsweise eine
Vorratsdatenspeicherung verhindert wo
wir solche Marktplätze die er geleitet
hat beispielsweise viel besser aufklären
könnten die entsprechenden Kunden viel
besser rückwärts beispielsweise
erfassen könnten und es geht nicht nur
um Drogen sondern es geht auch um
Kinderpornografie und viele andere Dinge
und ich glaube da haben wir alle einen
großen Namen also ich verstehe wo sie
hin wollen
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja so ein
riesen Thema ich glaube tatsächlich dass
man in diesem Bereich mit
Vorratsdatenspeicherung
so gut wie gar nichts mehr reicht weil
Täter so wie ich auch wissen natürlich
wie sie sich anonymisieren das Tor des
Werk an sich
ja richtig natürlich ich glaube
tatsächlich auch dass das
Strafverfolgungsbehörden durchaus
Möglichkeiten haben und besser geworden
sind es fehlt aber glaube ich an Geld an
Aufklärung und an Manpower wenn aber ein
Marktplatz oder ein kriminelles Netzwerk
groß genug wird und da tatsächlich auch
genug Manpower und Energie reingesteckt
wird dann bin ich schon davon überzeugt
dass deutsche Behörden BKA es bitte auch
oft international ermittelt sowas auch
bei uns das ist dann Möglichkeiten gibt
jeder zu identifizierende
Vorratsdatenspeicherung hilft aber nicht
sondern mehr Geld und Spezialisten wenn
es um IT-Sicherheit geht und Cybercrime
weil um das nochmal auszuführen
natürlich ist es so eine
Vorratsdatenspeicherung jemand der jetzt
sage ich mal unbedingt
vielleicht so den den Taschendieb den
den den selber wirklich kriminelle
Menschen die organis jetzt im
Internetkriminalität world Gruppen das
was wir gemacht haben Fischer die
Kreditkarten klauen die wissen natürlich
wer sich anonymisiert und da hilft eine
Vorratsdatenspeicherung von
kinderpornografieplattformen erwischen
sie mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung alle
so ja aber ich rede hier von also von
wirklich auch von von der Attacken das
ist ein riesen Thema in Deutschland also
fast jedes Unternehmen wurde schon Opfer
und da kommen sie mit und oder auch was
wir gemacht haben da kommen sie mit
fahrradspeicherung halt nicht sehr weit
und ich denke auch ne ich finde man muss
das machen auf jeden Fall und die Täter
sollen identifiziert werden so wie auch
wir und da muss auch da müssen auch
Straßen her ich finde aber
dieses Thema mit also ich bin wirklich
immer noch ein Freund von Datenschutz
und von Privatsphäre und ich habe auch
so ein bisschen das Gefühl
tolles Werk zum Beispiel Darknet ist ja
sehr negativ behaftet Anonymität wird
ganz oft mit kinderkidlich gesetzt und
das ist nicht so
Felgentreu wie ist denn die Politik
darauf vorbereitet also wenn man das
jetzt hört kriegt man ja schon etwas
Angst und Schrecken na sobald ich weiß
es hat sie gerade zum Thema
Vorratsdatenspeicherung doch im Urteil
gegeben auf europäischer Ebene das macht
jetzt der Koalition Kopfzerbrechen die
SPD war da eher auf der Linie von Herrn
Schindler die beiden anderen
Koalitionspartner sind da eher etwas
zurückhaltender aber was ich da jetzt
als Lösungen abzeichnet kann ich Ihnen
nicht sagen da bin ich bin kein
Innenpolitiker mehr deswegen bin ich da
nicht in den Details drin aber im Grunde
meine ich schon dass wir da mehr tun
müssen und ich kann ihnen auch aus
militärischer Sicht sagen es ist ja die
Bundeswehr hat ja praktisch als als
fünften Bereich des militärischen einen
Bereich für Cyber defence aufgebaut also
um wirklich Angriffe
im cyberraum auf Deutschland abwehren zu
können und das ist wichtig das muss
unbedingt gemacht werden aber da sind
wir das ist eigentlich auch immer noch
in den Kinderschuhen die Amerikaner auch
die Briten sind da deutlich weiter als
wir und auch das ist wieder natürlich
eine Geldfrage eine Frage des nur aus
und der Manpower da sollte man
erhebliche weitere Anstrengungen
Erfolgen aus meiner Sicht und dann gibt
es dieses Problem dass Sie angesprochen
haben mit der Frage wie wird man sich
eigentlich also eine militärische Logik
geht ja immer auch davon aus dass man in
der Lage ist einen Angreifer
abzuschrecken so und das ist bisher im
Bereich Cyber Defense kaum vorgesehen
das Cyber defence sieht im Moment
bildlich gesprochen so aus wir bauen
eine möglichst hohe möglichst
unübersteigbare feste Mauer und die
Angriffe prallen auf diese Mauer und
prallen von dieser Mauer ab aber wir tun
nichts um Menschen von Angriffen auf
diese Mauer abzuhalten und das ist auf
Dauer nach meiner nach meiner naiven
Verständnis vielleicht können sie da was
zu sagen ein zum Scheitern verurteilt
weil irgendwann findet einer einen Weg
durch diese Mauer
für ein anderes Mal aufheben denn wir
sind am Ende der Sendung angekommen
herzlichen meine Gäste und vielleicht
nehmen sie sich zu Hause Beispiel
debattieren Sie doch einfach mal mit
jemandem der so gar nicht ihre Meinung
hat schönen Abend noch und bis nächste
Woche Dienstag tschüss
[Musik]